right-handed domingo hermann in the
middle of his warm-up tosses this will
be his tenth start four and three record
the era just over three he's become a
reliable starter his last seven outings
four and one record the era just over
two and he throws his curveball a lot
all right so herman will have to uh play
the role of stopper today to end this
four-game
losing streak and the rays have won 16
of their last 17 that's the best stretch
in their franchise history grounded in
the hole backhanded by archela fires the
first and the scoop by ford they get a
rosarina for the first out moving to
second is lao that's some play by geo
rochelle at short whether it's third
base shortstop guy could play all over
the infield and again a nice play by
mike ford with the backhanded pick swing
and a miss big strikeout of g-man choi
two away meadows a left-hand hitter is
hitting 239 with power 12 former's 37
rbis but against hermon whoa
he's four for eight and of the four hits
three home runs swinging a long towering
side the deep right this one heading for
the second deck and that's where it
lands a two-round homer for austin
meadows in the first the rays take a
two-nothing lead in new york tough
right-hander and tyler glass now in the
middle of his warm-up tosses his 12th
start 4-2 record in the era very
impressive at
2.57 we'll look at our pitchers scatter
report on glass now coming off a
dominant performance against the kansas
city royals 102 pitches in that game he
struck out 11 and eight shutout innings
glass now pumps it home swinging a high
fly ball into left center field with the
rosarito moving back in front of the
morning track in front of the 399 sign
he catches it and judge is retired and
glass now with a one two three
two nothing tampa bay on the meadows
two-run home run into the second deck
and right field oh and two on one that
will be wendell kiermeier and zunino
in the second inning
the
o2 swinging a miss wendell down on
strikes second strikeout for jorman now
here's the 2-2
wrecking ball strike three
one two three go the raise third
strikeout for domingo at the end of an
inning and a half two nothing tampa ford
is eight for 57 that's something like
140 150 or so
the stretch by glass now in his 2-2
pitch breaking ball swung on a missed
frank three
that was a pretty good sequence those
last two pitches that glass now gave
ford
were uh
of big league quality
and there is a fastball strength three
called to sanchez over the outside to
retire
the side
six up six down two straight strikeouts
as well for glasgow no two down here's
randy a rosarina
and the fastball down to third and by le
mayhew rolling into shallow left and
duhar comes in
to make the pick up and holding it first
is a rosariana now here's the 0-1 to
choi
and it's hit in the ear to right
going back is frazier on the track makes
the catch and he hit the ball within no
runs no hits one error one left at the
end of two and a half
it's two nothing tempo
oh and he gets a strike call right there
third consecutive strikeout
against anduhar looking
yeah and duhar not real happy this is a
backup breaking ball you see the
curveball backing up it does catch the
zone
but anduhar duhar's thinking well that's
not where that pitch is supposed to be
here's the o2 pitch grounded right side
gonna be a tough play choi has it flips
over to glass now and they get the out
nice play by both troy and glass now
that was not going to be easy
and it goes three to one as joy got to
it and flipped it and led glass now
perfectly to get gardner at first it's
really tough because gmon's moving hard
there and in and had to throw it behind
himself well the yankees have what they
want they have the bases loaded two out
and here's aaron judge
and he walked him that'll force him to
run an rbi for judge his 30th fraser
crosses yankees
are now on the short end of a 2-1 score
another block by zumino and here comes
lemayo and he will score heads up base
running by dj lemayo to tie the score at
two
2-1 to count the pitch there's a swing
and a fly ball toward right but brett
phillips is there and he'll make the
catch and mercifully
the rays get out of it still tied
and he gets him to strike out
meadows swings and misses
again it's a changeup and it's not
really located well it's pretty much
right down the middle but the change
of speed and lack of velocity gets a
swing in the miss for her mom here's the
one two to wendell with two outs going
on
lined right to second to o'doul hit it
hard by right into the glove of rugey
three up and three down
man at the end of three and a half we're
tied at two for a strikeout victim his
first time ball game tied at two the
two-two pitch swing and a miss that time
he got a breaking ball that at least
made it through the dirt
two outs nobody on in a two-two game and
that'll bring up miguel on dua and duor
hits one deep to right phillips back on
the track see ya home run in duhar
and he's getting meggy with it he homers
again and the yankees take a 3-2 lead
kevin caramire leads off for tabwa
and he comes in with a fastball and that
ball tagged to right and that's going to
get out of here
3-2 and carr meyer hits the home run to
tie this game at three
pierre meyer's first home run of the
year
zunino down on strikes strikes out for
the second time against tremont
the 0-1 swung on hit in the air to left
and duo going back
makes the catch in deep left field
champion ties the game one run one hit
the home run by kier meyer
and now lawazziga comes into a situation
first and second one out and yandy diaz
is coming up
blocked by sanchez throw to first
got him
meadows too far off the back second time
that sanchez has done that in a couple
of games
sanchez starting to block the ball a
whole lot better keeps it in front i
don't know where meadows thought he was
going and mike ford comes behind him but
if you look at the throw it's right on
the money which makes mike sports job
so much easier big out here in the sixth
inning there's the 3-2 to wendell
struck him out swinging breaking ball
down and in no runs no hits
and two left here we go to the bottom of
the seventh we are tied at three
the yankees send up gary sanchez
ripped down the left field line it is a
fair ball one hop up against the wall a
rosarina gets the ball in quickly and
sanchez is in there with a lead off
double
ground ball shortstop got to play at
third they're going to get sanchez in
the rundown he's going to be tagged out
he
tried to avoid the tag and leave the
baseline
so he's out of there and the rays get a
break there dwayne this has plagued the
yankees all season long blunders on the
base pass
23rd game for green
swing and a miss got it right by him at
96 miles an hour
did he go
oh yes he went
troy down on strikes two strikeouts for
green first and third two men out this
might be the last guy the yankees want
to see up at the plate though joey
wendell and the one-two
swung on a high fly to right not deep
racing in as frazier dives and he made
the catch
oh my goodness frazier just saved the
yankees the new pitcher is jp firerison
he saved the game yesterday this will be
his 27th game he came over from
milwaukee so stanton will pinch hit the
go-ahead run is judge he's in second
runners lead at first and second the
pitch here's the swing of the ground
ball left side but right to joey wendell
he'll flip the second and that will
retire the sun fielder's choice goes six
to four and
that'll do it for the yankees in the
eighth we're gonna go to the ninth and
that's gonna bring up dj le mayhew with
a chance to win the game 229 with
runners in scoring position this season
kill two
and he aligns it caught by lau
on the right side at second base to
retire the side
and now the winning run is 90 feet away
george sheller with a chance to win it
and a swing and a miss kittredge a big
big strikeout of rochelle bases loaded
two out here's sanchez the 2-2
swing and a miss
he
struck him out we're going to an 11. the
winning run 90 feet away sanchez leads
off third the 0-1
swung on there goes deep left field it
is high it is far it is gone a walk off
bottom of the 11th game-winning two-run
home run
frazier
clint frazier frazier goes
downtown he hits a two-run game-winning
walk-off home run